- Do you feel like you're
a pretty good neighbor?
Like 'cause I feel like neighbors used to,
well I'm telling you you're fun to watch.
But I feel like when we were kids,
you knew all your neighbors,
but like now people don't
really know all their neighbors.
- So we moved into our
house during the pandemic,
which I think we talked about
cause you saw my terrible garage.
- Marie Kondo
But now that we've sort
of gotten to know them,
we actually also did this thing,
speaking of loving plants,
we started 600 milkweed seeds
because we became obsessed
with saving the Monarch
butterflies and helping them.
And so then we had this great idea,
like let's try to turn our neighborhood
into like a Monarch sanctuary.
So we sowed all these milkweed
seeds and then we like potted
them for everybody and put them
on our neighbor's door with
like my husband likes to paint
so he did like a little butterfly.
We had a lot of free time on our hands
- But it's so adorable
- And so now but it's so cool
when I'm slow jogging
through the neighborhood,
there's Monarch butterflies everywhere.
Like it really works. And
our neighbors loved it.
Like they genuinely-- cause
the first time it's like..
- I'm going to plant some.
- Yes. I should've brought
you some we still have some.
- I have butterflies all over my backyard
- Probably because you have
such good flowers and stuff.
- We have flowers everywhere.
- But the milkweed you'll
get the caterpillars
in the chrysalis,
which like for kids to watch, you know,
the butterflies grow
it's the coolest thing.
- Yeah. My eldest is just
learning that in school.
Like with science and stuff. Yeah.
It's really cool. But
every time you're here,
we talk about your struggles with anxiety.
A lot of people struggle with anxiety,
especially over the last two years.
So how's that going?
- Great.
No, no, genuinely.
- She's all like great...
- Guys I'm perfect now.
- Cause of my slow jog.
- I slow jog and everything's better.
It's actually going,
I don't know if we've
talked about it before,
but for years I've been doing
this meditation practice
called yoga nidra, which sounds intense
like you're doing asana like yoga poses,
but you're actually not.
It's the most like beginner
friendly meditation practice.
You literally like lay
down in like a cozy Zen.
Like you put a pillow
here and you can fall.
You can fall asleep. Oh, it's the best.
And like you get guided
through breath and through some
visualizations and everything.
And that has saved my life with
anxiety. I love it so much.
- Everything is about breathing.
- Yeah breathing and
coming out of your head
and into your body.
I loved it so much.
I just got my teacher
training so that on my podcast
I could lead people through yoga nidras,
and my first one is up and
you'll love this because it's
inspired by Dolly Parton's
light of a clear blue morning
because I got really
creative with meditations.
I'm really into like finding out how to
infuse creativity and music into it.
And so I love Dolly as we
all do. And so I wrote one
and it's up now.
- And if you don't get out.
- Yeah, it's on.
- Yeah. If you don't,
you're not allowed here
ever again ever again.
- That's amazing.
You have all these
fantastic things about you.
- I mean, I guess I have free time.
I will say I'm on a sitcom schedule.
I'm not on a Kelly schedule,
which is much easier.
- Mine's gotten easier, a little easier,
but is it true that you've
also found a way to combine two
of your other passions? This
I love. Wine and true crime.
- Sure have. With my
friends, Cassie and Mark,
we wrote a screenplay that
we just sold to Lionsgate.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- It's about a group of baby boomers
who love true crime and there is a
murder that happens and they
go on a mission to solve it.
- You have just described my friends,
they are obsessed with crime.
Like shows like everybody
who do you think did?
They're all like, did
you watch? Did you watch?
I'm the one that never
- You don't like it?
- Here's the thing.
I don't really want to be
scared. I'm in for the wine.
- Okay. We have our own
true crime and wine club.
- You will scare the crap out
of me and I will get drunk.
I will not want to live alone ever again.
- Two drunk scared girls.
That could be our thing.
Yeah that sounds elevated.
- Yeah. Two bougie drunk scared girls.
- Bougie drunk. See? We've elevated it.
- Two hippies, cowgirl,
bougie, drunk, scared girls.
- All the adjectives.